شوف انا لا ملك التوقعات ولا جاء اعطيك
توقعات صحيحه انا جاي اعطيك توقعات مبنيه
على احصائيات وارقام لفرق الدور ربع
النهائي لكاس العالم 2022 طبعا الارقام
دائما خداعه مش دائما تعطيك الصوره الصح
ولكن نحن بنعمل اللي علينا وبنشوف هل راح
تكون مزبوطه ولا لا اذا كانت مزبوطه
اشكرونا واذا ما كانت مزبوطه بيكون لا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله
راح نبدا
بالمباراه الاولى وهي مباراه البرازيل
وكرواتيا برازيل وكرواتيا الاثنين عندهم
حراس ممتازين طبعا ولكن حارس كرواتيا
يتفوق على اليسون بعد التصديات اللي
تصداها خلال البطوله 44 نهارس كرواتيا
مقابل 17 دفاعات الفريقين متقاربه
بالارقام تقريبا
لصالح المنتخب البرازيلي رغم ذلك كرواتيا
منظومتها الدفاعيه جيده عندها همم
غوارديول وعندها لوفرين قادرين يتعاملوا
بشكل صح مع الهجمات الخصوم وبالتالي عندها
منظومه دفاعيه في وسط الملعب كرواتيا نسبه
تمريراتها اعلى ب 100 التمريره تقريبا
بالمباراه الواحده من منتخب البرازيل
وبالتالي المنتخب الكرواتي عنده وسط ملعب
جيد بنسبه تمرين او بدقه تمريره عاليه
اتصل لحد 89% اسلوب لعب المنتخب الكرواتي
انه دائما بيعتمد على بروزوفيتش
بتوزيع الكرات بناء الهجمه بالمقابل عن
همم كوفاسيتش هو اللاعب اللي بيضغط على
الخصوم ومودريتش هو اللي بينقل كره من
ثلاث الى ثلاث اخر اكثر لاعبين كرواتيا
هجوما على المرمى بارزتش طبعا هو اللاعب
الاخطر راح يكون على منتخب همم البرازيل
لانه راح يكون هو الاقرب لانه يسجل الهدف
دائما بالنسبه للمنتخب الكرواتي حسب
احصائياته بالدور الاول وبدور 16 هجوميا
البرازيل تتفوق بعدد خلق الفرص بفرق شاسع
جدا جدا
بالفراص التي خلقها همم المنتخب البرازيلي
المنتخب الكرواتي ولكن نسبه الفاعليه
متقاربه نوعا ما
رغم انه البرازيل متفوقه بعدد الاهداف
هجوميا برازيل دائما تعتمد على ريتشارلسون
هو اللي يبلش عمليه الضغط على الخصم هو
الي ينهي الهجمه ومعظم اختراقات البرازيل
من الجهه اليسرى عن طريق بني سويف جونيور
وكذلك الحابه ما قلنا لك كرواتيا على
الجهه اليسرى عن طريق ايفان بيرستج
رافينيا دائما هو المسؤول عن رفع الكره او
عن ارسال العرضيات
بمقابل انه وسط البرازيل في كاسيميرو هو
اللي بيبدا الهجمه دائما وان له كسباكيتا
وان نيمار هو اللي بينقل كره من الثلث
الثاني الى الثلث الامامي ونيمار هو
اللاعب الاخطر عن المنتخب البرازيل الاكثر
خلقها للفرس نظرا لهذه المقارنات بنشوف ان
البرازيل هجوميا تتفوق بفارق يعني معقول
جدا عن كرواتيا وبالتالي ممكن نرشح
البرازيل انه هي تكون المتاهله الى دور
نصف النهائي ننتقل للمباراه الثانيه اللي
هي مباراه هولندا والارجنتين هاي المباراه
للكلمه تحير من بده يرشح فيها لحتى يصل
للدور الثاني بس خلينا نشوف الاحصائيات
مين مرشحه هولندا تلقت اهداف اقل من
الارجنتين هدفين تلقب في هذه البطوله
مقابل ثلاثه اهداف للمنتخب الارجنتيني
طبعا هجوميا هولندا تتفوق نسبه فاعليه
عاليه جدا عند المنتخب الهولندي تصل الى
57% هي الاعلى مع المنتخب الانجليزي بين
الفرق المتاهله الى ربع النهائي نسبه
الفاعليه طبعا تقاس بعدد الاهداف مقارنه
بعدد تسديدات على مرمى الخصم وبالتالي
هولندا نسبه عاليه جدا بالفاعليه وهذا
بيخدم اسلوبه اسلوبه اللي ما بيعتمد على
انك تخلق كثير فرص من المباراه ولكن لما
تخلص فرصه تسجلها في المرمى عندها هولندا
افضل حارس في هذه البطوله حتى الان من
ناحيه الارقام وهو اندرياس نوفرت لانقذ 52
ركز برقم 52 كره وهجمه على المرمى
الهولندي هذا رقم خيالي يعني ما بنفسه فيه
الا همم حارس البرتغال دييغو كوستا اللي
قريب منه شوي بهذا الرقم مع ذلك هو افضل
حارس في هذه البطوله على الاطلاق دفاعيا
مثل ما حكينا هولندا تتفوق شوي مع فرق
طبعا الجوده المنتخب الهولندي بمنتصف
الملعب الارجنتين كان ممكن لتكون متفوقه
لو دي بول موجود ولكن طالما انه ديبول
غالبا راح يغيب عن هذه المباراه همم الوسط
الارجنتين راح يكون بوضع صعب جدا وهولندا
ومتفوق بنص الملعب بالتاكيد عن طريق فرانك
دي يونج اللي هو اكثر اللاعبين جريا في
المنتخب الهولندي ودين بلند اللي هو اكثر
لاعبين ضغطا على الخصم وطبعا فيهم فريش
اللي بتعتمد عليه هولندا بالاختراقات
الهجوميه ودائما بتخترق من جهته 27 اختراق
او 29 عفوا اختراق من جهد دون فريس على
الجهه اليمنى لمنتخب هولندا وهي الجهه
الاخطر بالنسبه للمنتخب الهولندي
الهجومنيا هولندا مثل ما حكينا بالفاعليه
تتفوق ولكن الارجنتين يبقى انه عندها ميسي
واكثر اللاعبين محاوله على المرمى ايضا
على المنتخب الارجنتيني واكثر اللاعبين
فاعليه واكثر اللاعبين تاثيرا وبالتالي
ميسي ممكن يقلب الموازين هجوميا ولكن نسبه
الارقام هولندا هي المرشح للتاهل الى ربع
النهائي اذا نسبه لهذه التوقعات كان
توقعاتنا انه اليوم للدور النهائي برازيل
وهولندا خلينا نشوف شو راح يصير اليوم
وبكره جايينكم بحلقه توقعات خرافيه عن
مباراه المغرب والبرتغال ومباراه طبعا
انجلترا وفرنسا والبراي راح تشهد مفاجاه
كبيره انتظروني
[موسيقى]